bonjour à tous je suis c'est quoi le tec
tec aujourd'hui nous allons parler du
fonds monétaire international alors
c'est quoi le fonds monétaire
international
le fonds monétaire international est une
institution qui a pour but de garantir
la stabilité financière des pays mais
aussi de leur apporter des conseils
quant à leurs politiques économiques
il existe depuis 1944 mais à quoi
sert-il le fonds monétaire international
est très important son but est d'éviter
les crises économiques d'encourager la
stabilité financière et la coopération
monétaire internationale
il s'efforce aussi de faciliter le
commerce international devrait en faveur
d'un emploi élevés et d'une croissance
économique durable et enfin de faire
reculer la pauvreté dans le monde deux
kids est il composé il est gouverné par
ses 188 états membres qui cotisent pour
soutenir l'économie combien doivent-ils
payer le montant de la cotisation varie
en fonction de l'importance des pays
dans les décisions du fonds monétaire
international lui un pays fictif et plus
il pèsera lourd dans les décisions le
fonds monétaire international
possède-t-il beaucoup d'argent il est
doté d'un fonds de 750 milliards de
dollars soit environ 6 11 milliards
d'euros le fonds monétaire international
dispose d'une véritable stabilité
financière pour aider les pays en
difficulté en cas de crise mais
également pour les pays pauvres ou en
voie de développement qui peut emprunter
salon pays membres est emprunté au fonds
monétaire international il est en
situation de crise c'est à dire
lorsqu'il n'a plus assez d'argent pour
régler ces paiements internationaux ces
importations ou ses dettes qui sont les
principaux pays concernés les cinq
principaux pays emprunteurs au cours des
60 dernières années ont été le mexique
la corée du sud la russie le brésil et
l'argentine comment le fonds monétaire
international fonctionne-t-il il est
très bien organisée il a trois aussi
essentielle la surveillance l'assistance
technique et les prêts ils surveillent
les états membres et évalue la situation
économique de chaque pays il offre de
l'assistance technique et dé formation
pour aider les pays membres à renforcer
leur capacité à élaborer et à appliquer
la politique économique choisi il donne
deux pays membres une aide nécessaire
pour remédier à leurs problèmes
financiers le fonds monétaire
international occupe donc une position
centrale dans le système international
j'espère que vous avez bien compris ce
qu'est le fonds monétaire international
à bientôt pour un nouvel épisode